[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
this is the one plus five and just like
every smartphone in the past three years
there's been leaks there's been rumors
there's been renders there's been
speculation but now it's real it's here
in the flesh and this is everything you
need to know so one plus is history is
actually pretty limited in there a young
small company and because they're a
small company they actually don't have
the access to all this super high-end
tech that the apples and Samsung's and
Motorola's and HTC's of the world do
that's a disadvantage but the advantage
to being a small company is you can
actually listen to what your core fan
base and what your core customers
actually want and try to give them that
exact product so one plus 5 is another
incremental improvement over 1 plus 3t
with a few big bullet point changes and
a couple minor touch-ups so first thing
you'll notice is the insane specs you
can tell it's an enthusiast brand here
snapdragon 835 Adreno 546 or 8 gigabytes
of RAM and 64 or 128 gigabytes of
storage a dual camera system on the back
16 and 20 megapixel cameras bluetooth
5.0 a 3300 milliamp hour battery and a
5.5 inch 1080p AMOLED display and of
course an updated unibody metal design
ok so not bad let's break it all down
the all-new design is what's turning
heads this time you saw the renders and
then you saw all the replies you
probably saw all the YouTube comments Oh
from the back it looks like an iPhone
they're copying Apple they've become a
copycat company honestly I only agree
with some of this I mean obviously the
render is when we saw them from that one
angle that obviously looks like an
iPhone because it's got the dual camera
system up in the top left corner okay I
get that but honestly if you look at the
whole entire body of the phone it does
resemble some other phones even more so
than this one seriously how are these
not the same phone plus they've kept a
lot of the design cues from previous one
plus phones from the three and the three
t with you know the alert slider of
course in the
courts on the bottom in USB type-c it's
kind of like a Frankenstein smartphone
design pulling parts from a bunch of
different places but then again how much
do you actually look at the back of your
phone I mean honestly it actually has to
feel good more than it has to look good
and this one does it's seven and a half
millimeters thin it's got all these
rounded sides it's all metal but you
don't have to look at it as much as you
have to feel it and the one plus five is
a good feeling phone they kept that
alert slider which I like and always got
used to pretty quickly and of course
they kept the fingerprint reader up at
the front the same like last year in the
year before same size same position also
the design is kind of limited because
the only colors you can actually get
this phone in are literally black and
almost black which I love matte black
that's great but obviously if you want
some variety you can grab a skin I'll
link to these below it's a deep brand
skin and that's easily my favorite way
to add color to it without adding the
bulk of a case I highly recommend them
so this does mean you're not getting the
big bezel this displays that a lot of
phones have been moving too this year
and that we expected of the new iPhone
and the new pixel etc we still have some
pretty thin side bezels here but it's
definitely not quite the same effect I
actually found it interesting that in
the Verge's exclusive video of like the
making of this phone that they dropped
yesterday they actually admitted like
they would have liked to have done
something like an infinity display or a
bezel the screen but they just don't
have the tech to do it that's another
disadvantage of being a small company
now the dual camera system on the back
before we even get to photo quality is
already pretty interesting first of all
it's it's the headlining new feature
it's on the box right twice so it's
clearly what they want you to focus on
no pun intended but it is a 16 megapixel
F 1.7 primary camera with electronic
image stabilization and then a 20
megapixel F 2.6 telephoto camera as a
secondary on paper that looks pretty
good and then when you open up the new
camera app you'll notice it is a blatant
copy of the iPhone camera app no doubt
about that the 1 X 2 2 X button for
switching between the lenses is their
settings in the strip on the Left
shutter button on the right it's pretty
basic and then the slider of course
between the One X and the 2 X when
zooming in it's definitely a copy here
and no one can really deny that here's
the thing I've always said I don't
really mind if you copy stuff but if
you're gonna copy something copy the
good stuff so if you're gonna copy the
iPhone one of the best and most popular
phones
out there then yeah sure copy the camera
copy the fingerprint reader don't copy
the bad stuff don't copy like Siri or
something thanks B so this 1 X 2 2 X
button and the slider and everything in
the camera it's kind of the best way to
do it so I don't mind not being a copy
at all so how are the photos well
they're pretty good there's no doubt
that the sensor is capable of some
pretty great clean photos again I wish
it had optical image stabilization but
essentially this camera is a hit or miss
experience I've been taking photos with
this camera for more than a week now and
in just like everyday scenarios and a
lot of them turn out really nice some of
them though you'll notice turn out a
little weird dynamic range is pretty
much always great snapdragon 835 can
handle taking multiple exposures at the
same time so you'd expect it to be great
and detail is pretty much always on
point the center of the frame and
whatever's in focus is always sharp
colors and image processing were pretty
average I feel like nothing was pushed
too far in contrast or saturation except
maybe either Reds a little bit because
sometimes they got oversaturated but
otherwise it's pretty subjective whether
you like the look of a photo or not I
think objectively it'll score high on
camera benchmark tests because it's very
fast very sharp and has huge dynamic
range but side-by-side with the same
shot from pixel or an iPhone it could be
a toss-up which is quite good for a
phone at this price and then there's the
portrait mode from the secondary
telephoto camera
honestly overall this wasn't any better
than the same attempts from the iPhone 7
plus but also not worse kind of
struggles with complex edges but for the
most part it does a good job blurring
backgrounds obviously it does a much
better job on humans than it does on
less predictable less portrait subjects
and it still has some weird halo effects
near the edges but just overall it
doesn't quite match having a naturally
shallow depth of field obviously so if
you're into it you can use it I think
it'll get better with time with software
updates like apples has you know apples
was awful when it first came out and was
in beta but it's learned and it's gotten
better over time with portraits and I
think this one will too but right now
it's right in line with what we've
already seen so nothing's super new here
so you might be wondering why this
secondary telephoto sensor with the
worst aperture gets the 20 megapixel
sensor while the primary gets the 16
megapixel but their logic for that is
pretty simple it's that when you're
doing all that zooming and you go way
zoomed in you're using all the data from
the telephoto sensor so you want it to
be a
resolution so makes sense so beyond the
design and the camera and the specs a
couple more minor things are new and a
lot of the rest is the same stuff we've
seen from previous one-plus phones it's
great stuff but it's the same stuff so
battery here is 3300 milliamp hours so
not bigger it's actually 100 million
powers smaller than the 3t but the
battery life is about the same alas
comfortably all day thanks to the chip
and the display and that display that
1080p AMOLED display this is probably
the thing that's gonna get looked at as
the biggest downside of a phone when you
compare it to the more expensive
flagships but those are all the phones
that enthusiasts are also considering
buying so you kind of have to note those
all have 1440p displays or higher so
it's really easy to say oh this is 1080p
it must be awful but I'd always
challenge those people to really look at
the display and tell if it really does
look that much worse I mean when I first
got it first took it out the box when it
was brand new didn't even look at the
spec sheet and try to just look at it
and tell if I could see if it's a 1080p
display or did they finally move to
1440p and it took me more than just a
glance so it's a pretty good display
gets bright enough has pitch-black
blacks from being an AMOLED etc is good
and then of course that 1080p display
also means performance is a plus
Snapdragon 835 with the audrina 540 and
8 gigs of ram of course all pushing near
stock Android on a 1080p display it
better not hiccup this thing flies
through Android and that's its biggest
asset I think super smooth performance
tons of apps stay in memory for a long
time haven't had any memory leak issues
and that's credit to oneplus keeping the
same software philosophy again near
stock Android with a couple of
improvements no skin really no big
overlay just a couple tweaks thrown in
here and there in the settings that they
believe will improve the experience so
you can do things like switch between
the off screen or on-screen buttons
again with 1+5 you can still mess with
the shelf to the left of the home screen
by adding widgets to it or messing with
the built-in widgets that oneplus
includes or you can disable it
completely your call there's also now a
gaming do not disturb mode which halts
all banner notifications from popping up
when certain apps like games are open
the camera app now has a pro mode which
lets you go full-on with manual mode for
everything you know a per
sure focus distance white balance ISO
etc and it shoots raw and it even has
the level and a live histogram for
exposure
the extended screenshot mode is pretty
cool you start the extended screenshot
mode and it literally starts scrolling
infinitely until you tell it to stop and
then that's where the screenshot ends
it's pretty intuitive and it's just kind
of fun to watch it's well done -
charging is still awesome so if you're a
super heavy user and you get through
this whole thing in a day it recharges
as fast as any other smartphone out
there bluetooth 5.0 is onboard NFC is
not skipped this time the vibration
motor is a lot stronger and louder and
more noticeable so if you're into that
that's important and the microphones are
also improved now too so for recording
video and super loud environments these
will do better so is the oneplus 5 worth
your money well if you can get over the
design if you're not one of those people
who just wants to say it looks like an
iPhone if you can get over that then
yeah this is definitely a great phone
there's not a whole lot that you can get
with a snapdragon 835 and eight gigs of
ram and near stock android so if you can
get over the design and not having an
infinity display I think this is gonna
be a great phone for the money and I'll
give it a thumbs up don't get one if you
can I think you'll enjoy it that's
pretty much it
thank you for watching I'll talk to you
as the next one bass
[Music]